In this section we are going to consider another
spatial image processing operation, goes by
the rather confronting title of mathematical
morphology. Now the word morphology means
shape, so this is a type of spatial image
processing operation that is sensitive to
shape. The output image contains shapes that
are compatible with a structuring element
S. Now the structuring element is a pattern
which represents a subset of pixels within
the input window that we wish to consider.
An example will make that clear: we have a
contrived example here, simple binary scene,
black pixels and white pixels that contain
squares and rectangles of different sizes.
As in previous animations, we see the input
window shown here in red marching across the
image left to right and top to bottom. What
is different in this case is that the output
is only true if all of the pixels underneath
the red window are true. So far none have
been. In a moment we will see… this one
particular case now… where the output image
contains one pixel. That is where all of the
pixels underneath the red marching window
were all set. You will notice that most of
the shapes that were in the input image have
disappeared, the rectangles have all disappeared,
the little square has disappeared; the only
shape that was retained was the big square.
Note that the big square was the same shape
as the red marching window. We say that only
shapes that are compatible with the structuring
element—a 3 by 3 square—are retained.
This operation is also referred to as erosion,
because what has happened here is that our
3 by 3 square, even though it is compatible,
has been eroded away … pixels have been
chewed off its edges until only the centre
pixel is left. This operation is often called
erosion and this function can be computed
using the tool box function ierode; the first
argument is the image and the second argument
is the structuring element. In this case it
is a 3 by 3 matrix containing ones.
So we can perform the converse operation,
which is called dilation, and again we show
this in animation. Here is the 3 by 3 marching
window, but now for dilation, the output is
true if any pixel underneath the red square
is true. So far none have been. Now we see
that there are a bunch of pixels are going
to be set as the red window marches across
them and encounters a one pixel.
This operation is called dilation for the obvious reason
that it has taken a single pixel, dilated
it, grown it into a 3 by 3 shape; in fact,
it is back to the shape that it was originally.
This function, this dilation function, can
be computed using tool box function idilate;
the first argument is the input image and
the second argument is the structuring element.
So this was the original image that we had
and we eroded it to a single pixel and then
we dilated it so that the single pixel became
a block of 3 by 3 pixels. So you can see what
has happened here, we have taken an original
image, we have eroded it, dilated it and the
only shape that made it all the way through
was the 3 by 3 square. The rectangles have
disappeared and the little square has disappeared
and that is because only the shapes that are
compatible with the structuring element have
been maintained. Now this operation, this
sequence of erosion followed by dilation,
is often called opening. Only the compatible
shapes have remained and we can do this in
the tool box using the function iopen.
Let’s try doing things in the opposite order.
Let’s dilate first and then erode, so in
the dilation step we can animate this, and
for dilation output pixels are true if any
pixel underneath the marching window is true
and as we would expect for dilation the shape
is going to get bigger. But another interesting
benefit of this dilation step is that holes
within the shape are going to be filled in
and it has got bigger and holes within it
have been closed up.
Now we have the dilated image, now we can
erode it. So erosion is going to chew off
a strip of one pixels all around the outside
of this particular object; it is going to
restore it to something like its original
size and shape.
Now let’s look at the original image. Then
its dilated version. And then its eroded version.
And we can see we have something that looks
like the original shape, except the hole within
it has been filled in. This operation is called
a closing operation. It tends to close those
holes within an object. So any hole that is
smaller than the size of the structuring element—which
is a 3 by 3 pixel block—will be filled in.
This closing operation can be computed using
the tool box function iclose. So this brings
us to the notion of compatibility between
a structuring element and a shape. So here
a structuring element is a red square and
I am going to test it against a large square
and a thin rectangle.
So first of all we are going to test the large
square and basically it is saying that if
I can fit the structuring element within that
shape it will survive in an erosion operation
or an opening operation, but for the tall
thin rectangle there is nowhere within that
shape that the structuring element will fit.
So this shape will not survive, it will be
eliminated in the erosion step.
Conversely, if my structuring element is a
tall thin rectangle we will find that there
is actually nowhere that this tall thin rectangle
can fit inside the large square. So if my
structuring element is a tall thin rectangle,
this square will disappear. However, that
tall thin rectangle will survive, so the shape
of the structuring element controls the shapes
that will be retained in the output image;
it is a filter that is sensitive to shape.